okay
yeah you look
fantastic
i i love seeing you every time i see you
you always just give me something like
i just walked in and said oh canada
so how are we feeling tonight mind body
and soul entering these awards well i'm
actually really excited because i'm
going to canada like in a month on tour
i'm touring there in may yes so it's
been like forever since i've been there
because the pandemic like so sad so
crazy but um i'm really excited because
i'll get to see like my family on tour
and like my friends from high school
will come out to the shows and stuff
yes that's gonna be fun yeah that's
gonna be fun jlo has had so many like
iconic moments is there one that stands
out in your mind since she's being
honored tonight i mean she's just
amazing i'm so excited to see her like i
hope she walks by me so i can be like
see her in person person
she's amazing i mean she's an incredible
actress i love her films
romantic comedies especially in
particular
um
made in manhattan and i was waiting i
was waiting
classic right i could watch that over
and over
and like our friend tyler
posey's in it like he's a little boy
like he's my friend he's like a musician
now yeah
fun facts from avril oh my god okay so
when you get to canada next month for
your tour what is like your canadian
like have as soon as you touch down
poutine period cheese ketchup chips
swish la tim hortons
yeah you choose a drive through
immediately go to tim hortons get an
iced cappuccino and timbits and like a
dozen donuts
and then once i start i can't stop and
then i eat it every day and then i
go back to l.a five pounds higher and
i'm like damn it
worth it worth it always worth it and
it's always so lovely to talk to you
thank you for coming here you look
fantastic
we got a whole fashion vibe yes
thank you